et de quatre pour rafael nadal
l'espagnol a magistralement dominé le
numéro 1 mondial en finale de roland
garros
rodger federer n'a inscrit que quatre
jeux score final 6-1 6-3 6-0
rafael nadal a été exceptionnel dans
tous les compartiments du jeu
résumé de la rencontre christian réunit
tous les ans à pareille époque c'est la
même chose le même spectacle c'est le
rendez vous des adorateurs de la terre
battue
ouais c'est moi et ça fait quatre ans
que ça dure
bien sûr de faire un peu mieux
aujourd'hui que que quatre jeux mais bon
la file est vraiment très très fort 7
ans et l'a dominé ce tournoi comme peut
presque jamais avant de combien
alors il mérite ce titre c'est la
quatrième fois que nadal s'impose à
nadal expéditif 1 federer a sommé parce
que c'est la pire défaite de sa carrière
une heure 48 minutes sur le central pour
seulement quatre jeux gagnés 6 1 6 3 6 0
bien sûr le numéro un mondial s'est
défendu pourtant l'espace de trois jeux
au second set on a cru au retour du
suisse
une simple illusion à 22 ans l'espagnol
a littéralement assommé le numéro un
mondial l'homme aux 12 titres de grand
chelem est tombé sur un véritable mur
perdre en finale sait jamais trop drôle
mais en tout cas je vais essayer l'année
prochaine nadal a toujours faim de
victoires quatre victoires de suite
il rejoint björn borg au panthéon du
tennis nadal federer
ces deux là ils ont déjà signé pour se
retrouver sur le gazon de wimbledon
et ça ça sera une autre histoire